القصف والغارات طال مناطق مختلفه في انحاء
الخريطه الاوكرانيه بينها العاصمه هذا
الصباح فسكان كليب استيقظوا على وقع اصوات
الانفجارات بعد استهداف القوات الروسيه
لها باكثر من 15 صاروخ كروز قالت السلطه
الاوكرانيه ان دفاعتها الجويه نجحت في
اسقاطها جميعا
وجبهه الجنوب التي تشتد المواجهات فيها
بين الطرفين شهدت ايضا تطورات عده اذ
اعلنت الدفاعات الاوكرانيه اسقط صواريخ
روسيه في سماء مقاطعه
جنوبا ايضا وعلى ساحل البحر الاسود
استهدفت الصواريخ الروسيه منشات للطاقه في
مقاطعه اوديسا ما تسبب في انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي
اما في الجبهه الجنوبيه على ضفاف نهر دنبر
فقط تعرضت مدينه
لهجمه صاروخيه روسيه جديده كما اعلن دفاع
جوي الاوكراني رصد صاروخين موجهين نحو
مقاطعه دينيرو في مدينه كريفيري غربيه
المقاطعه
وكانت سلطات سودانيات اسكان مواليه لروسيا
اعلن الدخول القوات الروسيه مدينه
اوجليدار وتعزيز موقعها في طواحيها